chairman
thank you um good afternoon and welcome
to this northwestern area planning
committee meeting today wednesday the
23rd of september 2020.
my name is councilman mrs maddie
thompson i'm the chairman of this
committee
this meeting is held under the new
regulations which came into effect on
fourth of april in response to the kobit
19 pandemic there are just a few
housekeeping issues to run through
first of all please could i ask everyone
present in this meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted and your video
can
feed off excuse me we're not addressing
the committee this will reduce
background noises and avoid any
unintentional disturbances
the meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live and recorded
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent being recorded
members and officers during each time
item please use the chat function of the
meeting
to indicate if you wish to speak i will
then invite you at the appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak or that you
have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose
members when speaking and referring to
the gender papers please reference a
page or paragraph
number and keep your contributions clear
and concise as possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn your microphone on
and your video if possible now please
may i ask the officers taking part in
the meeting to introduce
themselves starting with mr lee who is
top of my list
mr lee good afternoon i'm
matthew lee and i'm lead specialist
place at morton district council thank
you
thank you mr johnson
thank you chairman michael johnson lead
specialist development management
thank you thank you ms bowles
good afternoon i'm hannah bowles i'm a
specialist in development management
thank you parker haynes
good afternoon i'm haley parker-haynes
and i'm a senior caseworker in
development management at malden
district council
thank you and um ms or mrs fuller sorry
i didn't ask first which you prefer
oh good afternoon my name is katie
fuller
i'm clark to this afternoon's committee
thank you any other officers present is
tara still
with us is she doing technical things
no tara will be in the background okay
thank you
um katie can you please now carry out a
roll call of members
to confirm those who are in attendance
thank you
yes chairman members i'll call your name
in alphabetical order please could you
indicate if you are present
starting with counselor bamford
yes from present katie thank you
councillor durham
apologies from her yes counselor jarvis
you're saying to katy present thank you
councillor keys
good evening afternoon present good
afternoon
uh councillor morley please present
thank you councillor
good afternoon katie present good
afternoon
uh counselor mrs thompson i'm here
thank you good afternoon everyone and
councillor miss white
no i apologize i think could you please
note her apologies
um and can we have other members not
members of the committee
but who are in attendance please
good afternoon and welcome good
afternoon councillor morris
i think that's it i don't see anyone
else thank you very much
uh so we've done we've actually done the
apologies all the way through that so we
have councillor
mrs fleming and councillor white okay
so item three on the agenda is
minutes of the 26th of august um
can i take those as read please members
agreed yes no problem does anyone have
any
queries about matters of accuracy
a great agreement hey does anyone
descent from agreeing these by ascent i
know that sounds barking but it's much
easier to say no than for it for
everybody to say yes
okay members can we agree these minutes
as they are
uh nobody wishing to speak as quite as
fair as i can tell
right item four declarations of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable peculiarly
pecuniary interests other pecuniary
interests
or non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they're also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting if anyone has an interest to
declare could you please use the chat
function
now and i will invite you to invite you
to speak i
know councillor durham has his hand up i
would appreciate being able to just rely
on the chat and not so much the hands
but i spotted you this time councillor
darren thanks
much appreciated chairman uh uh thank
you
i have a non-cunary interest as a member
of essex county council
who are consultees on items uh
relating to the planning applications
we're about to determine thank you
okay thank you very much uh no one else
no one else so we move to agenda item
five which is planning application
twenty zero zero six four one this is
land north west of fernbrook hall moped
lane
um mr bulls will present the report
we do have a submission from the
applicant
by mr stem the agent and mr johnson will
read that after the presentation thank
you so
off you're going spells please council
darren would you take your legacy hand
down please if it is a legacy hand
thank you so much thank you chair
so planning permission is sought to the
demolition of an existing stable block
and the construction of a five-bedroom
detached house
here we've got the location plan you can
see the application site here outlined
in red
we've got the block plan this is the
existing dwelling on the larger site
and the proposed dwelling
protein layout
existing stable block proposed to be
demolished
the front and rear elevations of the
proposed dwelling
side elevations the proposed dwelling
and the proposed floor plans this floor
plan here is
the basement level
this is the second story and this is
third story
and we've got some sight photographs
where you can see the existing stable
and menage
proposed location of the dwelling
this is the access here
some of the surrounding areas you can in
this photo here you can see the stable
block through the trees although it is
quite
small in the distance
so the application is a resubmission of
a previously refused scheme
the reasons for refusal relate to the
unsustainable location of the proposal
and the impact on the character and
appearance of the area the main
amendments to the scheme relate to the
design appearance and scale of the
dwelling
the amendments are not considered to
have addressed the previous concerns
raised
the application site lies outside of the
fine settlement boundary of wiccan
bishops in an unsustainable location
the proposed development is remote from
community support facilities and will
facilitate
unsustainable transport patterns
furthermore the development would have
an
urbanising effect on the real character
of the area and would result in an
unwelcome visual
intrusion and encroachment into the
rural countryside
therefore the application is recommended
for refusal
thank you chair thank you very much um
mr johnson would you be uh would you
read the submission from mr stamp for
the applicant please
so counselor okay
thank you um these are as a series of um
of points by uh the applicant
it is emphasized that the proposed
dwelling does not fall within the
ancient woodland
the ancient woodland is fenced off from
the existing access drive
and no pedestrians will enter the
woodland the previous refusal of
planning permission for a dwelling on
the site
did not refer to any harm being caused
to the ancient woodland
there is no reason why this proposal
should
disappointing to see that the report
makes no reference
to the offer by the applicant to enter
into a legal agreement with the council
to conserve and manage the woodland such
an agreement was encouraged by essex
wildlife trust
to conserve the woodlands the proposal
dwelling is a well-designed attractive
house which fits into the natural
landscape of the site
the design has been prepared by an
experienced chartered architect
the proposal results in a high quality
dwelling
it does not constitute it does
constitute sustainable development
and although some use of a motor car is
to be expected
it would not result in harm to the
council's objectives of sustainable
development
a large dwelling of such exceptional
quality
would not occur in a defined settlement
simply because the land allocation in a
defined settlement
would be developed as a housing estate
part of the character of wiccan bishops
is the large dwellings
built around the outskirts of the
village these properties are not located
within the definer settlement
the proposal will deliver a large new
dwelling which reflects the local
character and natural asset of the area
although the council can achieve a
five-year supply of deliverable housing
land
this requirement is not a maximum figure
the government
is looking to see a robust delivery of
housing
the definition of previously developed
land as defined in government advice
refers to the land which is or was
occupied by a permanent structure
including the cartilage of the
development land and any associated
fixed
infrastructure the proposal does
constitute previously developed land
the site is a windfall site for which a
housing allocation is made
for windfall development within the
local plan
the proposed dwelling would make a
positive contribution to the rural
economy of the area
and support local shops facilities and
organizations in the village
the existing building on the site is a
functional stable building
it is not attractive the replacement of
that stable building with an attractive
new dwelling
will result in a positive enhancement to
the character and appearance of the area
there is a difference in ground levels
between the site
and whitson road three dwellings to the
north on whittem road are clearly
visible
the existing ancient woodland does
provide some natural screening
it is not accepted that this
well-designed detached house would
result in the urbanization
of the area the council has slipped in a
third reason for refusal
the previous application for planning
permission made no reference
to the habitat regulations which were
existing at the time
the application the planning application
was determined
the applicant would be prepared to enter
into a legal agreement with the council
for a financial payment towards
mitigation services
in respect of the third reason for
refusal
in addition the applicant would be
prepared to enter into a legal agreement
relating to the future management of the
ancient woodland
on balance it is submitted that there
are real and positive benefits to the
proposals including
one a much needed new dwelling of
outstanding character and outstanding
design
two benefits to the rural economy of the
area
three support all the local shops
services and facilities
four improvement to the character and
appearance of the area
by the removal of the stable building it
is admitted that these real and positive
advantages
outweigh any perceived harms against
this background it is submitted that if
the council is minded to grant planning
permission
then it is requested that the final
decision is left in the hands of the
chairman of the planning committee
together with the head of planning
services to grant planning permission
once the legal agreements have been
entered into thank you chairman
thank you um i think i should note that
um
one of our officers mrs ward has joined
the meeting would you
introduce yourself mr sport
just for the sake of the public
yes hello there i'm nicola ward and i'm
just one of the planning officers
listening in
on the meeting today right thank you i
probably needed worried but thank you
uh councillor jarvis you called this in
and you had your hand up very quickly to
speak so i assume you'd like to go first
thank you very much chairman um okay i
think i'd like to
draw to all councillors attention of
certain aspects about this development
which of course is outside of the local
development
area it is a large property
that's been proposed but as most people
know
if they're familiar with mike lane it's
largely a lane of
large properties and i think um the size
of a
property has to be considered uh in
terms of being appropriate
uh as with regards to the size of the
actual site
i think the site's described as being
0.7
hectares but uh for those of us who
think of it in terms of acres it's
approaching two acres so this is a
fairly big site
uh and the size of the property
would represent uh less than ten percent
so this is
a big property but on a big site i mean
fernbrook itself is well over 15 acres
but
in a way that's academic so the site the
site where this property is
uh is approached in two acres and uh
proportionately
uh this doesn't to me seem to be a large
property
so sorry to interrupt your counselor
jarvis there was in fact a second
submission
neglected to have it read so i'm so
sorry to interrupt but
i'm happy to bishops parish council
thank you mr johnson
thank you and please please read it for
me
thank you chairman um
submission too from councillor richard
mundo chairman of wiccan bishops parish
council
recon bishop's parish council recommends
that this application should be refused
on the grounds of being in an
unsustainable location
and its conflict with policies s1 and s8
of the molden
local development plan the site is some
distance beyond the village
village's development boundary there is
no footway
from the house to the center of the
village either up
lane or wissam road both rose with a
national speed limit of 60 miles per
hour
by no definition could this be deemed to
be a sustainable location
on any of the three applicable criteria
and it fails the test
in policy s1 of the ldp
the existing property is set well back
from both written road and mode plane
and can hardly be seen the proposed
house would be clearly visible
from whitman road and would be an
urbanizing intrusion into the rural
landscape of the area
it meets none of the exceptions set out
in policy s8
of the ldp which seeks to preserve the
intrinsic character of the countryside
it will adversely affect the rural
nature of this location
there was a similar application which
was refused for many of these reasons
the paris council does not believe the
new application is materially different
in these respects in conclusion the
parish council supports the conclusion
reached in the planning officer
hannibal's report
and supports her recommendation that
this application
is refused thank you chairman thank you
very much councillor durham i've got you
but i'm going to go back with
humble apologies to councillor jarvis
who was mid-flow and i'm sorry i had to
pull you up
okay um i'll touch on a few of those
points um
that uh the officer also just mentioned
um so the size of the property is quite
large uh it's on a hill
which is very unusual but it's on a
hillside so
um you will see that in in certain
aspects it is actually three stories but
from looking at it from fern brook
and i have been to the site uh you will
only see two stories
uh and in fact um it's uh
uh so this is a fairly large house but
on a large plot
and as far as um being built on
redundant land is concerned i mean i
think officers have sort of commented on
this
look there is a stable there there is a
menage this is all being built
on land it's not chopping any trees down
at all this is um
uh the the i think the occupier used to
ride a horse
doesn't ride a horse anymore the horse
is being disposed of
and so this is essentially sorry
i'm gonna need to stop you just had been
apparently there's no live stream
oh heavens which means we can't nothing
we've done is of any value at the moment
when did it go do you know that no i
don't even have that
okay sorry too yeah it's a bit like a
dress rehearsal isn't it yeah because
as we know from discussions previously
if we don't have a if we don't have the
website working
not a public meeting um
it's not on the website or something
apparently the link isn't on the website
or something oh no
hang on let me go and have a look
you spoke very clearly carl thanks
oh i've got a bit more left yeah
what do you want me to do chairman
there's no point continuing we've got to
adjourn because this isn't
a valid meeting if we're not
live-streaming just to be clear
i've got more points from hm and
obviously
well unless we find out we might have to
go back to the very beginning does
anybody know
katie how you doing i believe um it is
on the
youtube channel the problem i've got is
there is a link that is
currently not talking from mod garb
to the youtube channel so there is it is
being broadcast on youtube
it's just the link from the calendar
in mod golf isn't linking to it
so we will would that only yeah would
that only be elected members then i have
to see it they i was here
uh well if if a member of the public
went to
the calendar they wouldn't be able to
click on the link and watch it if they
went to the malden district council
youtube channel they would how are we
like
the um we're actually going to have to
contact simon about this
because i don't want to we can't hold
the whole meeting and make decisions and
then
it's the planning agent that's informed
us that he can't see the meeting so
chairman i'm watching it on youtube but
um whether there was advanced notice of
that
find it
um i'm just having to look having a look
to see if it's on our
web page just distinct from mod.gov
because i'm not sure how many members of
the
public even know exists well my
understand is it's a planning
agent that's highlighted to us that he's
able to seize see the committee
someone who's got an item here right
i'm on click here to do the live
recording
oh there's a leg i'm going to turn
myself off i hate myself
the link on our website is distinct from
mod.gov works
and if we're saying
german i understand everything is
working
but with berna i didn't even know we had
yeah yeah same tara thank you i
oh officers tara what do you think
councilman everything is working now at
the moment
this is burner yeah
i think we should carry on if and the
link on the youtube home page is working
so there should be no
no problems okay if agents and their
applicants are trying to watch and not
managing to i think we'd know
okay gentlemen
where the web blink wasn't on um
our committee page he couldn't access
the youtube channel so i have advised
him to go onto youtube and view it that
way
um but i just wanted to let someone know
that it's not on the website for easy
access
can we just i might need those words
after all tara
um chairman i've rewound the youtube
feed and it does go right back to the
start of the meeting so it has been
accessible from the start of the meeting
understood my only worry is that if an
agent who's obviously interested in
at least one of these applications
couldn't find it
oh yeah can we confirm if the agent can
now have a look
[Music]
i'm just waiting for him to confirm okay
is simon in the building can someone ask
simon could i just also comment i mean
if if
some part of the meeting had been missed
assuming that may well be an issue oh
yeah
even if it may be working now um
well
so it is all available
i mean i got there from the mdc website
but are people going to know how to work
that out
because a number of links just have a
number link
i mean in my own mind i'm happy to carry
on but i don't want to get us into
legal difficulties so um
could someone tara maybe to try and
contact
simon chairman i'll contact simon thank
you
um to any members of the public who are
able to are we still streaming this bit
where are we adjourned i did say my did
something
[Music]
is that what you're going to say i was
just going to say just for clarification
i think there hasn't been a problem with
the streaming
the problem has been one of the links to
the stream yeah but i really
think you're right yeah that's
absolutely it
so um members i am going to adjourn the
meeting for 10 minutes which takes us on
you know 10 minutes i think that takes
us to 1 35 so if anyone does want a
comfort break or a cup of coffee or
anything
i will remain in the meat
um hello and welcome back to this
meeting of north west area planning
committee um i'm reopening the meeting
as
i said i would at 13 35
um we've been advised that we're from
our legal advisor that we are
safe to carry on i understand that
everyone
who was queering uh whether they could
get into the meeting is now in
but um and it is all on the on the
youtube
channel but for completeness and clarity
i'm actually going to begin again at the
beginning of item five which is the
application
that i am north west of fernbrook called
mo plain
so um i will call on the officer to
present the item in a moment and
we have two submissions both of which
will be read by our officer mr johnson
okay so um miss bowles report please
thank you chair so planning permission
is sold
for the demolition of an assist an
existing stable block and the
construction of a five-bedroom detached
house
we've got the location plan you can see
the site outlined in red
we've got the block plan this is the
existing dwelling on the larger site and
the proposed dwelling
got the proposed site layout
the existing stable block proposed to be
demolished
front and rear elevations of the
proposed dwelling
elevations of the proposed dwelling
closed floor plans you've got a basement
um level
ground floor level and first floor level
we've got some sight photographs the
stable blocker menage um where the
proposed dwelling will
will sit
some of the surrounding area here
the application is a resubmission of a
previously refused scheme
the reasons for the previous reasons for
refusal related to the unsustainable
location of the proposal
and the impact on the character and
appearance of the area the main
amendments to the scheme relate to the
design appearance and scale of the
dwelling
the amendments are not considered to
have addressed the previous concerns
raised
the application site lies outside of the
defined settlement boundary of wiccan
bishops in an unsustainable location the
proposed development is remote from
community support facilities and would
facilitate
unsustainable transport patterns
furthermore the development
would have an urbanising effect on the
rural character of the area and would
result in an unwelcome visual intrusion
and encroachment into the rural
countryside therefore the application is
recommended for
refusal thank you chair
thank you very much right mr johnson
submission one please which is from mr
stamp speaking to the applicant
thank you thank you chairman
it is emphasized that the proposed
dwelling does not fall within the
ancient woodland
the ancient woodland is fenced off from
the existing access drive
and no pedestrians will enter the
woodland the previous refusal of
planning permission for a dwelling on
the site
did not refer to any harm being caused
the ancient woodland
there is no reason why this proposal
should
disappointing to see that the report
makes no reference to the
offer by the applicant to enter into a
legal agreement with the council to
conserve and manage the woodland
such an agreement is encouraged by essex
wildlife trust
to conserve the woodland
the proposal dwelling is a well-designed
attractive house
which fits into the natural landscape of
the site the design has been prepared by
an experienced chartered architect
the proposal results in a high quality
dwelling
it does constitute sustainable
development and although some use of a
motor car is to be expected
it would not result in harm to the
council's objectives of sustainable
development a large dwelling of such
exceptional quality
would not occur in a defining settlement
simply because the land allocation in a
defined settlement would be developed as
a housing estate
part of the character of beacon bishops
is the large dwellings built around the
outskirts of the village
these properties are not located within
the defiant settlement
the proposal will deliver a large new
dwelling which reflects the local
character
and natural asset of the area although
the council can achieve a five-year
supply of deliverable housing land
this requirement is not a maximum figure
the government is looking to see a
robust delivery of housing
the definition of previously developed
land as defined in government advice
refers to the land which is or was
occupied by a permanent structure
including the cartilage of the
development land and any associated
fixed
infrastructure the proposal does
constitute previously developed land the
site is a
windfall site for which a housing
allocation is made
for windfall development within the
local plan
the proposed dwelling would make a
positive contribution to the rural
economy of the area and support local
shops facilities and organizations in
the village
the existing building on the site is a
functional stable building
it is not attractive replacement of that
stable building with an attractive new
dwelling
will result in a positive enhancement to
the character and appearance of the area
there is a difference in ground levels
between the site and whitton road
three dwellings to the north on britain
road are clearly visible
the existing ancient woodland does
provide some natural screening
it is not accepted that this
well-designed detached house
would result in the urbanization of the
area the council has slipped in a third
reason for refusal
the previous application for planning
permission made no reference to the
habitat regulations
which were existing at the time the
application was determined
the applicant would be prepared to enter
into a legal agreement with the council
for a financial payment towards
mitigation services
in respect of the third reason for
refusal in addition
the applicant would be prepared to enter
into a legal agreement relating to the
future management of the ancient
woodland
on balance it is submitted that there
are real and positive benefits to the
proposals including
one a much needed new dwelling of
outstanding character and outstanding
design
two benefits to the rural economy of the
area three support all the local shops
services and facilities
four improvement to the character and
appearance of the area by the removal of
the stable building it is submitted that
these real and positive advantages
outweigh
any perceived harm against this
background it is submitted that if the
council is minded to grant planning
permission
then it is requested that the final
decision is left to the hands of the
chairman
together with the head of planning
services to our planning permission
once the legal agreements have been
entered into
thank you sorry submission yeah
submission two uh from councillor
richard mundo chairman of wickham
bishops parish council planning
committee
we ship i'm sorry we can bishops paris
council recommends that this application
should be refused
on the grounds of being in an
unsustainable location and its conflict
with policies s1 and s8 of the molden
local development plan
the site is some distance beyond the
village's development boundary
there is no footway from the house to
the center of the village
either up malt lane or within road
both rose with the national speed limit
of 60 miles per hour
by no definition could this be deemed to
be a sustainable location
on any of the three applicable criteria
and it fails the test in policy s1
of the local development plan the
existing property is set
well back from both wisdom road and
mobile plane
and can hardly be seen the proposed
house would be clearly visible
from whitman road and would be an
urbanizing intrusion
into the rural landscape of the area it
meets
none of the exceptions set out in policy
s8
of the local development plan which
seeks to preserve the intrinsic
character of the countryside
it will adversely affect the rural
nature of this location
there was a similar application which
was refused for many of these reasons
the parish council does not believe the
new application
is materially different in those
respects
in conclusion the parish council
supports the conclusion
breached in the planning officer hannah
bold's report and supports her
recommendation this application
is refused thank you chairman thank you
uh right members i should point out that
the members update
um contains references to this
application and also the next one
and the next thing to say is the
recommendation is to refuse
for the reasons as detailed in section
seven of the report
i'm going to put that on the table
without committing
either way to vote vote for it but do i
have a seconder yes chairman i'll second
that cancel that
now we have something to debate as as i
said that there is no
obligation to vote for your own proposal
or for one who seconded
otherwise you'd be pretty predetermined
thank you councillor jarvis you've been
so patient and i'm sorry you've got to
take it from the top but i'd rather
think you have
thank you chairman i thought i was
appearing in groundhog day for a moment
but uh here we go
[Music]
we've heard those reports from the
officer and a number of letters
well it is a big property um but it is
on a big site
uh i think this needs to be taken into
account moblane
is is really largely all large
properties
that's the character of that particular
streets so this is a large property but
going on a site which is nearly two
acres
um it is also um i've observed
that the property is at three levels uh
and from some perspectives but that's
because it's on a hillside
so from fernbrook uh it will appear as a
two-story property
and it will only appear uh as a
three-story property
uh frankly if you're actually on the
driveway because
i would challenge whether you can see
much of the property
uh from the roads i think was quite
apparent from one of those photographs
which we saw a moment ago
as far as the um uh where it's being
built
is being built on a menage and uh the
um the essentially redundant uh
functional building of a stable so it's
really important to understand that this
is
this is not being built in the middle of
the countryside and knocking some trees
down this is being built without removal
of any trees
and this is being built on essentially
land which is
previously developed so i think that's
important
um it's a good design i don't i think
the officers have sort of commented i
don't think anybody's disagreeing it's a
good design
and it's in keeping this is very
important i think in keeping with the
street scene
largely uh in this particular area the
street scene
would probably constitute fernbrook
itself as the nearest property but it's
the design is in keeping with fernbrook
which i think is an
important aspect um i have read you know
it's got some
good green green credentials i felt
looking through
and they looked to me to be addressing
sort of bio
issues habitat issues
i thought some people might have a
concern about road access but
there is already a road access which is
to the stable block was currently a
second access road
for fernbrook which is the road access
that will be used
for this new development should it get
built so
there is no additional road access issue
and
i think the main issues for objection
which come from
officers and also from the local parish
is clearly on the fact that it would be
an invasion of the countryside this is a
phrase that's been used
and unwanted visual intrusion well as i
say if we could get the photograph back
up
um from the stable block from mate lane
and uh i'll be uh i think if
chairman if it's possible to have a look
at that it is if we could
i'm not saying if you were standing in a
ditch and you had a pair of binoculars
and you studied it long enough you
probably could spot the stable but
you know this is um uh essentially this
is not a property which
is going to stand in your face if you're
going down uh if you're going down mate
lane and i go
up and down lane all the time so
photograph bottom left
okay so spot the stable well you know
you can sort of see it
and this is at a time of year where
there's no leaves on the trees
right so in a situation like that you
can probably just about see it
so for most of the year you would not
see that at all
and even at this time of year whether or
not he's on the trees you won't see
what you can hardly see it so i think to
say that's the visual invasion
of the countryside is uh is an
inaccurate statement this is not
open countryside this is um mass
woodland
and there's woodland all around it and
so
i don't think uh from moat lane you
would you would see this
from um the photograph bottom right
there is obviously taken
from wisdom hill again a road i'm very
familiar with and all i can say
is i think to actually see this property
which will be set quite a way back
from uh from from that boundary fence
you can see on the right
uh that woodland would all stay no trees
coming down
and the property set quite a bit back
you would have to
i would challenge crash counselor mandel
to say that uh you know you would see
that
i do not believe you you'll see this
property unless you're literally
standing on your seat looking out of
your sunroof i should say there are some
properties on whistling road
which are very much in your face and and
perhaps
but that's another issue but this
particular prophecy will be shielded by
woodland
and will be set quite a way back so i
would uh challenge the concept of being
an intrusion
on the countryside um the issue of
sustainability is uh is obviously a
point which both districts and parish
have
mentioned of course we all want
properties to be sustainable
but look um yes everybody who's right in
terms of
nobody in their right mind would
probably walk up with some road because
it's a busy road
but nobody does walk up with some road
but what people do do
what i do and what i know people who
live in my road do
is they walk up moat road and then they
walk up church road and they go to the
shop
people do walk to the shop obviously
people will also drive
but it's quite walkable to get to the
village shop not up with some road which
would be
the nearest route as the crow flies but
also it is a busy road
but people would walk up moat lane and
then walk up church road
and they would get to the village shop
like that i know uh most of the
residents
in lane that do that and i know that the
karen occupier i've
seen the current occupier do that and so
i think it's
um a stretch to say that there is no
definition uh
which would describe the new property uh
as sustainable
because if they can walk to the shop um
i i would define that as meaning the
prop new property was potentially
sustainable um i'd also just like to
make reference there was a property
which uh councillors will be familiar
with
uh at the top the other end of my lane
which i went to inspectors
where it was clearly determined that uh
if a property
uh on the sustainability argument it was
discerning that the property
proposed development on land next to
little hill was
sustainable and for the very reasons
that uh um
it was uh relative still relatively near
the center of the village
and also because that property was going
to be set back there was a natural
shielding which meant that there wasn't
an intrusion on the countryside
well i can tell you if that's the case
for little hill that's definitely the
case
for the proposed development that's
being uh proposed near to fernbrook
because there is a
massive wood not just a thin bush line
that would provide some shielding i'm
not aware that anybody
my last point is i'm not aware that
anybody's objective so look this doesn't
overlook a footpath this doesn't
uh stand in anybody's face there are no
neighbors who've got issues with this
nobody has objected to this i understand
the parish council
objection um but uh nobody uh living
nearby it
has a problem at all uh with the
proposal
so chairman those are my sort of points
on this for to sort of open up the
debate
i would like to have the option of
coming back and just summarizing
prior to voting please john thank you
um right well you've had about 10
minutes so far so we'll see how the
others go
um councillor durham i have next
followed by
councillor civil councillor keys i hope
i've got that right so council darren
please
thank you chairman um chairman
um yes i have sympathy with uh
councillor
um councillor jarvis's um
statements there and nobody can doubt
that it's not going to look out of place
along
lane actually rather small in comparison
to some of the other
properties along there but um there are
a couple of
couple of points and and i i tend to uh
be siding with wiccan bishops parish
council um
on their views this is a previously
refused
application and again it comes down to
policy
and you know having having sat
at almost every session over the space
of about 18 months
the examination in public to
for our ldp i get increasingly
frustrated that our policies are
um basically being ignored i will with
your indulgence
um read from the constitution uh on
planning protocols part 5 section 2.5
which clearly says the ldp is adopted in
the interests of the whole community
following public consultation it
therefore represents the overall public
interests
rather than those of individuals or
organizations
councillors and officers must support
the council's planning policies
and make decisions in accordance with
these
and section 2.8 goes on to say while
councillors may sense a particular
responsibility to serve their ward
electors
they have an overriding duty to the
people of malden district
as a whole you know these policies are
there
for the protection of the entire
district and as much as we may want to
override them we can't pick and choose
which policies uh we choose to follow
and those we choose not to
um and you know we we can't uh elect to
draw rules
bring these policies out uh when it
suits us so
you know has to be one rule for one and
one for
all i'm afraid and you know this clearly
is a new dwelling in the countryside out
of the defined settlement boundary
contrary uh to to policy and
you know this equally applies to the
next item on the agenda
and and you know as i said you know
the po the council protocol clearly said
you have a responsibility to serve the
entire electorate of the northern
district
irrespective of our local um
local issues so i'm you know yes
i i totally agree with nearly everything
that councillor jarvis has said but i
i side with the um with the parish
council on this
and i will be supporting the
recommendation to refuse
thank you thank you all right i've
and councillor keys and then councillor
bamford so
council said all please okay thank you
chairman uh
in terms of this particular property uh
i can't see how
it's increasing urbanization there are
houses
on the other side of blue mills hill
which are far more visible and far more
urban there is there are properties very
very close to the road
in terms of its sustainability and its
access
this property is approximately 100 yards
from a bus stop
so even if people did want to get to the
village by public transport
they are able to do that via the bus
stop which is just around the corner on
blue mills hill
this will have no impact on the woodland
the woodland has not been affected as
car
councillor jarvis has said this is on an
area which has already been developed so
it's using developed land
i feel that the building is of a good
design
and will fit within the landscape and in
terms of there being no footpaths
yet again we've had this argument there
are no footpaths there are no footprints
out much like my house
there are no foot bars in lots of areas
we live in a rural area
and therefore there often aren't
footpaths so to use that as a reason for
refusal
is very questionable thank you
thank you council keys
oh god uh considerable and council jobs
have stolen a lot of my
thunder but we live in the countryside
we judge
every independent planning application
on the merits in front of us
and i think the older ones of us on here
will remember
as you go down blue mills virtually
opposite mope lane there was a caravan
that was then passed as a building
permission we live in a country we walk
on the
verge we don't have street lights we can
get to the shop as
councillor siddal said there's a bus
stop down there there's already a
building in the woods yes it houses
horses not people
but i have got no problem with this
whatsoever
thank you okay so we have
council banford please
thank you um i did second
the officer's recommendation that you
put to the committee
the reason why i did that is exactly the
same
as what counselor durham has said the
previous
application for this site which was
smaller
um does not this new
this new application does not address
the reasons for refusal of that previous
application
so we've already turned down
a smaller house on this plot
for reasons as has been pointed out
it's outside the development boundary
it's not on a sustainable
location and it's contrary to various
policies
in our local development plan and those
are the points
that we need to address here um we can't
really now turn around and say well this
is a larger house
so we're going to ignore everything that
we said before
and we're going to agree it um it isn't
addressing any of the other reasons the
reasons that we
turned it down before
and so therefore the officers have got
this right
it is against the policies in our ldp
and that's the important point as
councillor durham has pointed out
so madam chairman i'm
totally in agreement with what the
officers have said they've put in a very
good report on this
and um i'm happy as i said before
to second the proposal for refusal
thank you thank you right i've got mr
lee would like to speak
mr lee thank you chairman um just wanted
to come back on a
number of points that have been raised
during the debate
um to be honest i'm a little bit
disappointed with some of the comments
that have been made by members
um the starting point for the
termination of any planning application
is the development plan
um that is the law that is where we need
to whether it's officers members the
planning spectra whoever
that is the starting point policies have
gone through
uh examination in public they've gone
through evidence-based and
as a council and the council is an
entity
it's not just how members or individual
officers feel is what the council
decided is that
we have drafted settlement boundaries
and that we
are trying to provide new residential
dwellings within those settlement
boundaries
or within the allocated sites if we
considered that
additional large properties outside of
the villages was acceptable
we would have introduced a policy that
supported that as a council we have not
and a policy does not support that
um you know cancer durham through
quoting the actual thing
made reference to the fact that you know
the decision-making process is in the
benefit of the district
and that how whether it's officer
members we need to
deal with the policies as a starting
point so i won't bother to repeat that
because i think you dealt with it better
than i would do off the cuff to be
honest um
but in relation some of the specific
points um
the site is privacy development land
um but the mppf highlights that that
should be used when it's within a
settlement boundary and as
members are aware this is not within a
second boundary and therefore
that is of to a certain moot point is
not the starting point for
consideration particularly actually as
our policies would support the provision
of stables and menages in rural areas
such a position has been put for by a
number of members that because there is
a stable on here we should put
be allowed to put dwelling in is a very
very dangerous statement to make
the fact that there are agricultural
buildings or the fact that there are
buildings that
uh except when in rural area are on site
it should be allowed for dwellings is
totally contrary to our policies
and actually would make an unbelievably
dangerous position um and as i said
before
every decision is a material
consideration in future determination
application
and an inconsistent approach or a
worryingly becoming consistent approach
for members
will erode our ability to resist and
adversarial applications going forward
so i'm very worried about some of the
things i've heard today to be honest in
relation to
applications of policies and the
requirements um
our policy states that anything outside
of settlement boundary is the
countryside
and countryside is not just made up of
beautiful rolling fields
it is made up of woodlands it is made up
of agricultural buildings it is made up
of
a cacophony of different types of sites
but it is not
made up by large dwellings and the fact
that there may be
certain dwellings within sites certain
dwellings within areas
and whether they're sustainable whether
in their flood risk etc
the fact that they're there does not
automatically mean that additional
development should be allowed when it's
contrary to policy
classic example is uh it's flooding
before pps
25 was introduced in the early naughties
there was no
requirement for flooding on in planning
decisions so you wouldn't have been
worrying about it so just because houses
are in flood zones doesn't mean we can
allow more
and that goes the same in unsustainable
locations just because there are
dwellings
that are in understandable locations
does not automatically mean
that we should allow additional ones
um and i think quite importantly i'm
sure
members familiarize themselves with the
appeals that come in
um and they are circulated them but end
of last week an appeal was received in
relation to hackman's lane
in clocks in [ __ ] clerks and i think
that's quite an important decision
because actually
it reflects in terms of the points of
this application
um and this application was refused on a
number of points one of them no being
the character of the area and one of
them about the stove
sustainability of the location the
inspector actually found that that
application was acceptable
in design grounds because one of the
better words it was an infill
development but the inspector still said
that this site because it
it's remote from day-to-day facilities
and the
need to rely on a car that that was
unacceptable so it's a multifaceted
approach so even if you do not think the
dwelling is going to particularly erode
the rule capture the area that doesn't
automatically make its standard location
and we've consistently refused
applications when they are include
relatively close proximity to a shop
or a bus stop with limited resources
because that is not sustainable
in the big picture and such an approach
erodes our ability to defend
other sites and you know this is
something that we are consistently
winning at appeal and i'm very worried
about members
statements today that completely go in
the opposite direction to everything the
officers have been doing since the
adoption of the ldp in relation to
our policies what members have been
doing at planning committees and the
appeals that we have been winning
based on those decisions because these
are not
these are such generic statements that
have been made i'm really worried to be
honest
um as part statements such as we live in
the countryside well
some people do yes but the policy allows
for that and
that allows for dwellings certain in
certain instances
while another instance it doesn't and
that's the point we've got to look at
what our policy says and
in this case this is conscious policy in
relation to council keys
point on the caravan if i remember
correctly that was where the caravan
had been had operational development
occurred so it was lawfully a dwelling
and our policy allows for replacement
dwelling so
that is not material consideration
deterministic application because
our policy does not it actually
conflicts with our policy
replacement of agricultural buildings
with dwellings um
i think that's probably most what was
said and
yeah i hope that i've covered all the
points
well said matt sorry matt well done i've
actually got
um counselor darren would like to come
back council jarvis you did say you'd
like to summarize i'm going to leave you
to the end but you will only have
a minute at most because i'm very
generous with timing but
that was a long time last time around so
counselor
yeah chairman uh mr lee has has in no
uncertain terms explained
the the ramifications of this and you
know we
we we fought very hard for a local
development plan to protect the district
and now we're choosing to undermine it
which as mr lee has said
will not give us the opportunity for
refusing
dwellings when we want to refuse them so
what we're doing is effectively opening
the door
so you know we will only have ourselves
to blame
when an application comes along and wins
on appeal
in in a location that none of us around
this
i was going to say around this table
around this meeting
may support but because we have
undermined our
the the the policies in the local
development plan
uh you know
well i i i i'm really concerned that's
his ass is mr lee and i'm sure the other
officers
and uh you know if we may as well just
scrap the ldp
and and revert to um uh presumption in
favor of sustainable development
because that's where exactly where we're
going to end up and uh
it's going to be a free-for-all we're
concerned enough with the
changes to the planning system which is
going to double our required delivery
potentially
and you know but those those additional
300-plus houses they're going to be in
areas where we don't want them
and uh we'll have to give ourselves a
hearty pat on the back
uh for opening the door to developers so
please please
follow the policies that the council
strove for many many months and many
hundreds of thousands of
years into position thank you
thank you i'm actually going to add a
two pennies in that i'm obviously of
course there's several meetings i've
heard well
the village is unsustainable so what's
the difference well the point is that
we try not to add to these difficulties
yes we live in the countryside yes
people have to manage without footpaths
but there's no need to add to those i
mean the only
actual solution for an unsustainable
village is to
flatten it and build it somewhere else
so we're obviously not going to do that
but what we do do
is try very hard not to make it any
bigger not to add to the problem mr lee
i hope i haven't just stolen your words
do you chairman um yes or no partly
there was two points where to come back
one was on the fact that i didn't
i dealt with that matter and i think
you've pretty much
covered it perfectly the other thing i
wanted to say was that
i've heard a couple of times
the phrasal very similar to i don't have
a problem with this
um that's not the thought process behind
the
determination of a planning application
the starting point is
the policies um i under completely
like to take into a perverse situation
you go well i don't have a problem with
mr smith's immunity space is annihilated
by the
the neighbor having an applica extension
it's not about whether or not you have a
problem with it personally
you know i might i have different
opinions and different values for what i
consider
the robustness of some of our policies
are but that's not for me to
do as a decision maker because by law
i'm to start with our policies
um if material considerations were
against them or admitted considerations
were
in favor of going against our policy
that's fine and that is
as members know something you'll often
see in reports to help balance in
exercise
but just saying i do not have a problem
with the development is not a reason for
approval because
you need to see why you as the decision
maker
as a knowledgeable reader the fact is
you are not just a member of public
making decision
in how you feel you are here as a
knowledgeable reader an informed
decision maker that starts with the
policies adds appropriate weight to
material considerations
and then comes to an informed judgment
then the whole point of the planning
system is it is a plan led system
that provides consistency and
understanding to the public
and not using appropriate policies or
not until situations and just basing it
on how your heart feels which is
unfortunately not the planning system
it's a quasi-judicial process and that
you know it's just so i'd want to
highlight members the fact that how you
feel about an application
to be honest is an irrelevance just as
much as how any how i feel about it or
how any of the officers feel about it
and how the inspector will feel about it
it's about starting with the policies
thank you chairman thank you um and one
other thing i thought i should mention
is the fact that there aren't objections
and i'm not talking about this case in
particular but very much in
general people tend not to object
because they want to carry on getting on
with their neighbours
even if they're not happy about it and
they do rely on the decision maker to
make the right decision without
them having to say anything
adding to that just to um confirm that
that's actually exactly what the case
law says basically
the judge said that it is responsible
decision maker
to make the correct decision based on
policies and that
members of public rely on decision
makers making the correct decision
predominantly because they do not want
to fall out with their neighbours so
it's not just specifically to this but
generally
but that is what the case law actually
says is it's pretty much exactly what
you said
thank you thank you like house of jarvis
i mean please feel free to come back on
these
points but there's um there are aspects
like over development of the plot which
no one has actually raised a difficulty
with because it is as you say
a very large plot so if you could just
come back on um
the matters that other people have
raised thank you
hi joe thank you um can i just ask first
of all if everybody
all other officers have said their piece
chairman
i certainly haven't seen anyone else
okay
everybody done we're done carry on
counsellor okay um
i mean i noticed what counselor durham
said um obviously i'm aware
of what the local parish has said um
he's councillor jeremy said we shouldn't
we can't pick and choose but you know
frankly
i think the whole point of the um the
process we're going through now is that
we afford different judgments different
weights um to various different elements
so
um largely it seems to me that what
planning committee here
or what we do if it was as black and
white as some people have just
determined then obviously there wouldn't
be much point in us meeting so i have to
say i think
in a lot of cases what we're doing is
giving weight to various aspects and
i certainly perhaps get by the sounds of
it i i think i would
uh conclude that i give more weight to
the fact that it's a good design
you can't you can't see it from any
particular aspect
uh there are no trees being taken out
and um you know i think it's uh it's a
sort of property that
complements the street scene where it is
you know i've tried to i've tried to
look i think it's been sort of
portrayed that this was our gut feeling
from me or from other
councils that we should just do this
this isn't the case i've studied this
i've visited the property i've studied
the plans
and i know mo ray lane very well so
i think it's slightly insulting to
suggest um that
this is just a gut feel this isn't a gut
feel i've actually gone through and
studied and i think that this is an
exception
and i think that's what this planning
committee is here for to to use our
skills and our judgment to add weight
if it was simply up to officers
obviously this committee wouldn't have a
function so
i do believe i respect other people's
judgments other people's
comments that they've made and i respect
myself
but you know we are here as a committee
to give our judgment as councillors
and so um as i'm sure you can tell i'm
in favor of this particular property
each property on its merits each
property uh
should be considered on its merits and
in fact uh to quote counselor durham we
are here to serve the electorate i
absolutely agree
but we're here to serve the electorate
every electorate even the electorate
that are putting up a property which
might at first glance appear to be
against
rather straight off the point i really
do want to take this
yes thank you chairman i concluded my
comments so
um katie are you taking the wrong call
are we ready yes chairman so
thank you we are voting to um refuse the
application
as uh per the officer's recommendation
so members i will take your names in
alphabetical order please could you
indicate if you are
for against or abstain starting with
councillor bamford
four thank you councillor durham
councillor jarvis
against
the keys against
wally against
against councillor thompson
oh thank you chairman
that is three four and four against
no chairman need reason for approval oh
sorry no not yet
members if members are two yeah
right um okay the recommendation falls
but that doesn't make it automatically
approved which
mr lee was about to point out so what we
now need is a proposal i'm actually
looking to you councillor jarvis in all
probability
um but we
we should not be just approving this and
i'm going to ask you to look at item 21
of um mr submission
that if the council is i'm quoting is
blinded to grant planning permission
then it's requested that final decision
is left in the hands of the chairman of
the committee together with the head of
planning services
to grant permission once the legal
agreements have been entered into you
know i have to be clear we haven't got
the legal agreements
we should not and i think must not
just plain grant permission the other
thing is we have to address each
reason for refusal which well i've just
done the third one which is the legal
agreements
um council of jarvis off you go proposal
please
thank you chairman so just on that last
point first regarding any legal
agreements perhaps
officer lee can just clarify i mean any
um i think there was
talk of a habitat agreement or by
agreements about the woodland i mean
those issues can just be put down as
conditions
uh on approval would that be the way to
deal with those
obviously mr ling
um no that wouldn't be the correct way
the only way to
um garner the rams contribution is to a
6106 agreement
that's why there is that reason for
refusal down so
as with all applications that have been
overturned for dwellings recently and
ones that are up for approval
the recommendation up should be from the
committee would be to
delegate it to myself and
subject to the completion of the section
106 and on a
fairly complex application like this i
would suggest that conditions should be
delegated as well alongside uh
consultation with the chair
the interesting point is the ancient
woodland where
officers do not see there's a need for
that to be
particularly managed through a
unilateral undertaking and
to honest uh to use to
sum up to a point pulled out of clay i
think this is almost been put forward as
an opportunity to try and buy a planning
permission as in
you shouldn't be using the section 106
which is outside or
onerous i'm not saying that i'm using
that in an appropriate
i'm just using that in the case law
terms that it would be seen as this was
trying to be an offer that would
actually go outside
what i consider the planning application
i know essex
wildlife have suggested that but i don't
think it's necessarily
necessary for us but then again we
didn't support the application anyway so
if members thought it was necessary
that's up to them
okay thank you chairman well i mean yes
german three i mean if if essex wildlife
have recommended
something it's probably not unreasonable
that the applicant an agent have thought
that might be something that was useful
but
i think generally it sounds as if those
sort of issues
are are best left to yourself and
matt lee to service so putting those
issues to one side quite clearly the
applicant
who currently lives obviously in the
ancient woodland and has done for some
time
i understand you know he's obviously
very um uh very
con concerned and uh uh very happy
to accommodate any conditions that
relate to proper use of the woodland
habitat etc it would see
so in terms of um uh reasons um for
approval
um you might have to help me uh
obviously which i know might go against
the grain a bit obviously because
you're recommending refusal but um i
think um
i do recognize the very important point
that where we are
recommending approval for something
which is against the local development
plan we should be very
clear about the reasons for approval so
that we don't set unwanted precedence i
do understand that point
i i i do believe that um uh it's a good
design
i think the design aspects it's in
keeping uh with the street scene
um this is obviously an aspect and
they're not reasons for refusal
the reasons for approval have to address
um the only way i would be able to say
that you'd be able to say the design
is a reason for approval is if i'm not
sure what the section is it used to be
such
uh paragraph like what the paragraph is
in the new
mppf in relation to exceptional design
i don't think even the applicant is
trying to put forward as his exceptional
design
and i'd be very he used that word
officer i would be
very worried to
argue that this is exceptional design
taking into account
guidance should be it's a big difference
between science and attractive
development
or it's focused for the area or it's you
know even a beautiful event
the exceptional design is a unbelievably
high threshold that i think we've
allowed one
in the time i've been here and we've
refused a number and one appeal
so i think yeah members should be very
careful of the wording that's used
because it will set
fundamental pref us questions
about your experience obviously i mean
obviously i'm just mentioning things
which might be
selected um it's i did see the
expression that it was an exceptional
design
and i noticed officers haven't hadn't
sort of objected to that and in fact
made comments that they thought it was a
good
high quality design so but i think um in
terms of the weights given
to uh the fact that it's
the intrusion on the countryside i mean
i i i i don't think it is i don't think
i think we saw evidence from the
photographs that it can hardly be seen
even when there's no leaves on the trees
so my view whether you can uh adapt this
as uh
as a reason for approval reason for an
exception would be that you can't see it
and so from no footpath or from no road
can you
realistically see this uh probability uh
and i i think um you know that in itself
means that
uh there is uh not not uh not a huge
amount of weight clearly
i would have thought given to the
intrusion of countryside expression
that's used and
the other point if i make the other
point that you can come back on both of
them
is in terms of um in terms of uh
it being uh sustainable um
i did mention the case uh little hill
where i'm pretty sure the inspector
referred to um that proposed development
as being
uh as being sustainable uh and that is
in moatlane
and um and i think uh uh and i
referred there to the fact that uh it
wouldn't be an intrusion
and wouldn't damage the street scene
because uh it would be screened off by a
hedgerow and i think as i mentioned
previously
this is screened off by wood so i don't
know whether you can build something
there
obviously and assist me uh in in putting
forward good reasons
um for making this an exception
i've got a quick question for mr lee did
we have a five-year
housing land supply when that other
permission was granted does anybody know
you chairman that's what i'm trying to
look up because obviously
it's always helpful to have stuff like
this before the committee so yeah
definitely knows
it's much higher when you have a when
you have a plan and a five-year housing
loan supply
does counselor jarvis know roughly when
this permission was granted that he's
making reference to i'm sorry
um obviously no i mean i know that uh
recently there was a real
reapproval of potential property
development the other end of moblane
little hill
and i remember you know thinking about
that permission
to want to vote a replacement permission
for one of the better
words would be very different to a brand
new complication
yeah through you chairman i just
remember the specific comments on
sustainability which was my point in
raising it
where they are where the inspector
argued that in fact
um they felt that that any development
there would be considered as sustainable
and also the fact that they considered
um the screening of the
the hedgerow uh would mean that there
was little weight should be given to the
intrusion in the countryside that's the
reason for mentioning that case
and uh i think uh both of those aspects
are
equally true if not more so regarding
the wood screening
i'm obviously leaving it to yourself
officer lee to try and assist us here in
uh coming up with specific
yeah thank you uh count uh ms bowser if
you've got an answer for the
issues i think you might you may have
dealt with some of the applications
around there
the property that was approved at little
hill
um it was originally approved in 2016 i
believe and it was at a time when we
didn't have a five-year house in land
but
so the the goal post move yeah because
for clarity for members
clarity members in times like that we
our
housing location policies fall away so
there are no settlement boundaries
and everything is done as a balancing
act and there is the
tilted balance in favor of development
because we didn't have a five-year land
supply
so in that instance is the starting
place for the termination of plan
applications the mppf
not the development plan so that would
be material clearly different to this
situation it should not be given full
weight in the termination of any
application subsequently
the only difference would be would be if
for example a planning permission was
still live or something like that
where then that would that stamp
permission is a material consideration
so
those circumstances are totally
different yes and
through you chairman i understand
obviously but have you got the comments
there that the inspector made regarding
sustainability
do you chairman no i haven't because
you've just sprung it on me for one of a
better phrase ten minutes ago
um okay but the point is that it's a
tilted balance
exercise rather than it being that
it it fundamentally changes the the
balance in exercise so an inspector
would have to
weighing up the fact that we have no
five-year land supply is processing
a much more intriguing i'm not intrigued
i'm almost forensic analysis of the pros
and cons of the development
and weighing in favor the fact that you
need to deliver housing when you
aren't delivering enough that is
material and significantly different to
the situation we have now
where you're talking about people not
having footpaths limited public
transport
and us being able to deliver a five-year
land supply as always members i'm
i'm happy to help but the problem is
that sometimes my professional advice is
just that
that's not acceptable you know um i
can't i'm
at the end of the day the gifting
decision makes to come up with the own
decision but
you know i can all i can advise is the
weight that we can give to the various
material considerations because
as members will know from reading the
appeal decisions
inspectors give very limited weight to
our appeal decisions that were allowed
dwellings outside
boundaries before we had a five-year
land supply that is a consistent
approach by inspectors and i think
generally whether you agree or don't
agree with what officers say
a rule of thumb is to see the
consistency that
inspectors do or don't give way to
different matters because
at least they could be argued to be
independent and the variety of them
provides a level of consistency that
should hopefully gain some weight
thank you chairman thank you i don't
want to go around instead
of paraphrase on that the thing is
without the five-year housing land
supply outside the development boundary
without it we have to prove that
something isn't sustainable
when we have a five-year housing land
supply and a local plan
the applicant has to prove it it is it's
different balancing act altogether
right councillor jarvis but we need what
we need i'd like to look forward to
the proposal that the property proposed
development is of an exceptional design
and that it is uh in a sustainable
location
uh and that it is uh not considered uh
to be an intrusion on the countryside in
view of the screening afforded
by the um by the um
uh ancient woodland i mean i won't go
around in circles on this obviously
that would be my past i've got to ask if
you can't see it
what difference does it make whether
it's an exceptional design on that
okay good job
but i've got to be honest the use of the
phrase that this is an exceptional
design i think is very
dangerous that has a very significant
power for one of a better phrase through
the mppf
and i would have grave concerns about
using this because it is low
creating a very low threshold for what
moulder may consider as an exceptional
design going forward
and secondly to say that this is a
sustainable area
can't blanch would then mean that you
know
anything in my plane is sustainable
whether it and you know just because
it's got limited view so we could put 15
houses
in a field that you wouldn't really see
is basically what the argument that
you're putting forward is and
this is my worry with a lot of the cons
um
my recommendations for refusal getting
overturned recently is that
there seems to be no site-specific
weight being attributed it
it's just eroding our policies and our
position
and these are generic responses or
generic
position statements from councillor
jarvis that could be
regurgitated again and again against us
in sites here i've got your capital
south east
you know across the district and members
need to be conscious that when making
these decisions and they need to
highlight
site specific reasons why a scheme is
acceptable
generic was if you want to say it's not
visible or hardly visible on there for
the balance which
is a worry you know but i can understand
the argument it's there's some level of
subjectivity
but statements about things being
sustainable statements about things
being exceptional design
are very dangerous and should not be
used
willy-nilly thank you chairman
councillor darum i've got you you uh
yeah thank you we're just going round
around in circles
once again we've got ourselves into a
right pickle
um i i do recall the one or two
occasions where we have granted on the
base of it
being exceptional design and and that
this
this uh although this is acceptable and
he's not i'm
enough you know i i don't have any
problem with it it certainly doesn't
come under the
uh description of exceptional design and
uh
so i think we could say uh and and again
that mr lee has
outlined the reasons why would be
dangerous to call the area sustainable
because it isn't under any circumstances
i think we need to just say
that that um on on balance
the the harm um
there is there isn't significant harm uh
and
uh it's an acceptable design
uh and that it's replacing an existing
building all of which are fairly tenuous
and fairly lightweight
but i i don't see us any other any other
option
really we certainly mustn't go you know
calling it um an exceptional design
because as mr lee said there are pretty
pretty hidden criteria for what is
exceptional
you like them or not i didn't
particularly like the one will be
granted but there you go
um so yeah i just think we need to say
that that
the the um that it isn't going to cause
undue um harm to the area and that's
about as good as we can get
it's more subjective um still
have you know it still is not
particularly
site-specific but is stronger than has
been um
it's you know the issue is when you look
at the previous reasons for refusal or
the current reason for you still
um to some extent reason for two
is you know there is an erosion of the
area rural area
um and that you know if you're saying
there's limited impact then obviously
that's fine um proficient to section 106
obviously makes the third reason for
refusal
i do have concerns about overcoming the
reason for sustainability
um but that's within members gift you
know i can't
force members to do anything but you
know
we are in it you know we are in the
situation we are at the moment thank you
i think mr lee if we we can highlight
some of the other properties along that
plane i mean it is it's
it's fairly renowned for having you know
quite a lot of very
large um very large um
uh breeze block mansions us council of
batteries to refer to the mass
i think um so
that's about as good as we we're gonna
get i mean you know we've yet again
successfully driven the coaching horses
through our ldp and which we
i'm 100 certain will come to regret in
due course but
there you go well
okay um
can you support that counselor jarvis
um i i'm not trying to cause any issues
i think i put forward
uh my recommendation but i'm happy to
tell you i think council terrorism has
been very constructive there
obviously we don't want to aid in um i
do consider matlane
to and obviously obviously has
given his professional advice as to
perhaps uh slightly more narrower
reasons for supporting it
i'm happy to take advice on that uh and
if counts if officer lee wants to sum up
what he feels is
the most appropriate uh uh in the
circumstances
uh the most appropriate uh proposal i'm
i'm
happy to uh have you to support that it
has to be
well i'm uncomfortable proposing it
because i think
because i'm going to vote against it but
there you go um
i don't think we're going to get any
better mr lee i very much i'm sorry
about that
the chairman for clarity and for members
clarity
reason for approval is something that
has to come from members
um reasons for refusal i'm able to put
in planning terms
when it's broadly discussed and
highlight those
a reason for approval has to be clearly
outlaid but this is what the law
says case law says clearly outlayed by
members on so that the public
can understand their reason for going
against
the policy so while members may think
i'm particularly obtuse or problematic
when it comes to reasons for approval
that's because by law
i have to be it's not that i'm trying to
be unhelpful it's that
this has to allow the public to clearly
understand why members have gone against
officers when coming to their decision
so it's it is different to when you're
talking about conditions or anything
like that thank you chairman
understood so but is that the valid
proposal as far as you're concerned
well i think it'll be about goods um
okay that's the proposal we've got
members it's been seconded
could we have a roll call please cody
yes chair um so we are voting to approve
the application
contrary to the officer's recommendation
with the legal agreements and conditions
delegated to
officers subject to a section 106
agreement and in consultation with the
chair
councillor bamford against
thank you councillor durham
uh against bizarrely thank you
councillor jarvis i think i'm four
you councillor mr thompson again
that is four four and three against
thank you very much so that is um
well approved subject to delegation of
all those other matters to
the officers and myself thank you very
much so now we go
on to gender item six the agricultural
barnes adjacent to 31
plains road little totten no brake totem
i apologize
uh just the one submission to
follow the presentation please
haley who's parker haynes is that a
legacy hand counselor darren
thank you off you go sorry
i haven't got a present yes i have thank
you
can't hear you thank you thank you
planning permission is sought for the
demolition of the existing agricultural
styled outbuildings and the construction
of two detached residential dwellings
with associated landscaping and vehicle
parking
the existing buildings have a lawful b8
storage and distribution use
it is also proposed that the land to the
north will be restored to open
countryside
this application is a resubmission of
planning application 20062
which was previously refused by members
at the 8th of june committee
scheme in relation to scale sighting and
design remains unchanged
additional documentation has been
provided as part of this application
in an attempt to overcome the concerns
raised from the previously refused
scheme
a full breakdown of this can be found in
section 3.1.6 of the officer's report
which is pages 29 and 30.
this is the location plan
this is the block and parking plan
these are the existing elevations
these are the existing floor plans
these are the proposed elevations for
plot one which is to the western side of
the site
these are the proposed floor plans for
plot one
these the proposed elevations for plot
two
these the proposed floor plans for plot
two
these the existing and proposed street
scene elevations
and these are some photographs of the
site
the applicant has submitted additional
information to correct what they
consider to be misunderstandings in
the consideration of the previous scheme
and further emphasize that the site is
brownfield land and therefore consistent
with the government agenda for the
redevelopment of brownfield
land over other land it is not
considered however
that this additional information would
overcome the previous reasons for
refusal or lead the local planning
authority to a different position and
what is essentially the same proposal
as argued and accepted previously the
proposed development would result in the
removal of former agricultural styled
buildings which are reflected with the
rural area
in favor of two residential dwellings
the application site is remote from
community support facilities and would
facilitate unsustainable transport
patterns
furthermore the development would have
an urbanizing effect on the rural
character of the area and would result
in a string of prominent
residential dwellings and a dense form
of development contrary to the existing
grain of development along this stretch
of plains road
the proposed villains would harm the
character and appearance of the rural
area contrary to policies s1
s8 t1 and d1 of the modern district
local development plan
and planning principles and guidance
contained within the national planning
policy framework
therefore this application is
recommended for refusal thank you
chairman
thank you we have this time just the one
submission which
is from mr calder the applicant and mr
johnson's going to read that for us
thank you
thank you chair
members would have noted that this
application is a resubmission of the
original planning application
discussed at may's committee meeting the
applicant noted the discussion between
members of the committee
and planning officers who raised a
number of matters
some of which were based on factual
inaccuracies
which the applicant felt undermined the
proposed
development and ultimately contributed
towards this refusal
members noted that the application site
comprises a number of old and tired
agricultural style buildings
these buildings are of no architectural
merit and do not positively contribute
to the countryside
the existing buildings on site are
however
in a lawful b8 use they may be of
agricultural appearance however they are
not
agricultural buildings during the
deliberation
the buildings were repeatedly referred
to as agricultural buildings
and members were subsequently concerned
that their demolition and replacement
with residential dwellings
will set a precedent for other
agricultural buildings in the district
to be replaced with residential
development
officers will know that this would not
be the case
as firstly each application will have to
be dealt with on its own merits
and secondly a precedent can only be set
if an identical site stroke scheme came
forward
for the proposed development in any case
with the buildings being in bh use
this would be materially different to
any other agricultural buildings
thus clearly not impacting on or setting
a precedent
for any future proposals for the
redevelopment of existing lawful
agricultural buildings we would just
like to draw your attention to the
loss of employment justification
statement
that was submitted in support of the
previous application
and resubmitted as part of this
application
during the committee's deliberations
officers repeatedly stated
that the proposed development was
unacceptable due to no
justification for the loss of employment
having been provided
this is clearly incorrect this
resubmission
has also been supported by an additional
chartered independent professional who
supported the loss of employment
justification statements findings
another matter we would like to
reiterate is the proposed restoration
of the rear of the application site to
open countryside
which will inevitably have a positive
environmental impact
no reference was made to this and we
would expect
that this environmental benefit should
at the very least
be acknowledged in light of the above
we would ask members to reconsider the
individual circumstances of this
proposal
and the significant positive benefits of
the scheme
which includes the removal of the
possibility
for the site to operate as a storage or
distribution center
with no restrictions and the provision
of a sensitively designed development
that would be more in keeping with its
immediate surroundings
thereby enhancing the character and
appearance of the site
and that of the surrounding area thank
you for your consideration
thank you chair thank you before i put
the recommendation i noticed
mr lee would like to make a comment
thank you
thank you chairman for clarity obviously
um just want to make some comments on
the
applicant submission um obviously which
is heavily
laboured around the previous debate my
direct collection of these conversations
are slightly different to the
applicants i think it was acknowledged
that the buildings that were
industrial use but the buildings have
historically agriculture have appearance
of agricultural buildings
therefore that is why they were
discussed as appearing as agricultural
buildings
rather than as appearing as employment
buildings um and therefore
that was the discussion about the loss
of the agricultural buildings and how
they ever
will feel etc so the actual use of
inside of them is an irrelevance
and i think that was something that was
discussed or of limited weight maybe
rather than any relevance
secondly in relation to
each application is termed on its own
merit
so don't disagree with that obviously
that's always the way but each
decision is material consideration and
the council's policies
does not support loss of agriculture or
loss of agricultural buildings for
residential sites either way so that
would still be
a material consideration that would be
of equal weight so i don't agree with
that point
and in relation to the employment aspect
um while information had been submitted
it was not considered to be fully robust
including lacking the
advertisement of the site as required so
therefore
the statement that a full employment
statement or support of the policy
requirements hadn't been met
is accurate because as explained within
the officer's report
in section 5.2 this still hasn't been
met so
i just wanted to clarify the points that
the agents raised and just say that
my recollection is very different to
that and just wanted to put forward
my two pennies worth thank you chairman
thank you
uh right i'll move to the recommendation
which is to refuse for the reasons
detailed in
section 8 report and i need to remind
members that there is an update on this
one which was
emailed to you earlier and is on the
website as well so i'm sure you've
read it um would someone second this so
that we've got someone somehow
happy to second chairman thank you
councilman darren
um councillor all you call this in so
let's
come to you first unless you'd rather
take a different turn
no i'm quite happy to go her first uh
chairman thank you
uh the reason why i called it in is i
called it in
uh the last time as well is i feel
that in terms of this particular site
this isn't some kind of twee farm it's
not
a farm with some nice barns that a
weatherboard and a traditional
essex style this is several concrete
with asbestos probably in them buildings
and then behind that a huge range of
broken down wooden buildings which serve
no purpose at all
so in terms of the the site being
agriculture
yeah and it is classified as a business
it is more industrial
than than uh agricultural so therefore
in terms of any urbanization and in
terms of converting these buildings into
two properties i think there will be
less urbanization
if we take that approach the transport
issues come up again
in terms of the reasons for refusal in
terms of the distance between this site
and the bus stop
it's not 0.4 miles not 0.7 miles
as specified by the officers and
as i stated i think last time the
transport requirements for
a business and uh operating from there
would have a huge effect rather than two
uh reasonable size residential
properties these new properties aren't
dense
there's are they are well uh it's closed
uh separated
and also in terms of the
land behind it it's again less urbanized
because
they are restoring land to countryside
as a result of the properties
the in terms of design
this development and the look of this
development is exactly the same as the
properties that are further up the road
so we're not talking about building on a
field we're not talking about
building on land we're talking about
redeveloping
brownfield site which is part of what
the government wants us to do
yes it is outside the settlement
boundary but i feel that because it's
redeveloping
banfield site that outweighs that
particular thing and
it will enhance the rule area that's it
thank you um i do have a little reminder
that i appreciate some of us are in
rather remote areas
and we don't have the bandwidth to use
our video but if if we could that would
be appreciated i think by members of the
public
um right i have council down next
thanks very much indeed i can't disagree
with anything councillor siddha said and
if ever there was a
um an application that deserved to
um go against the ldp it's probably this
one to say that that site has
little architectural merit i think he's
been kind to it exactly it's an eyesore
and i don't think anybody will
anybody anybody will say anything else
and you know what he's proposed
will uh indeed be an improvement but i
have to
fall back on our policy situation
i'm afraid and at the moment and i sort
of say at the moment
um it's contrary to policy so
um i you know i can't be hypocritical
and
and go for this one uh whereas i've
objected to others on the same principle
but um so yeah it it it would be very
nice to see that those uh
that this particular site tied it up but
um yeah it's contrary to policy and i'm
afraid
as mr lee has said everything has to
start
and should finish with policy although
that hasn't happened in the past but
thank you chairman
thank you um actually i don't believe
there's anything in planning law that
stops
the site being cleaned up it doesn't
need planning permission for something
else to make that happen i don't
believe anyway i have council jarvis
next
anyone else could you put your names on
the chat please
sorry jim did you ask a meeting i didn't
quite hear you i did you're next on the
chat
oh okay thank you yeah thank you
chairman um
yes i mean i just uh noted what
counselor darren said then and i
think what he said was was right up to
the point where perhaps
in one way um perhaps some people feel
entirely constrained by the policy i
mean i think each case on its merit
in this particular case i don't think
anybody would suggest that that site
looked a complete mess and obviously
what's being proposed would look much
more appealing
and so i find it i find it um
fairly fairly easy to support um
this particular application um and uh
in this particular case as i say each
case on its merit um
i'll let others speak but that would be
how i feel about it gene
thank you i've got councillor banter
next
and in their glass unless anyone else
would like to answer the
list
you want um to speak chairman yes please
when you're ready
when you're ready thank you well i have
a lot of sympathy with this
um and as councillor jarvis has said
each planning application on its own
merits
however we do have a local development
plan
and as it says in the report
um that the government are encouraging
development of brownfield sites for
housing
but only if they're within the
settlement boundary
and unfortunately this site is outside
of the settlement boundary
so you know we've got to take all these
points into account we can't just
dismiss them because we want to tidy the
site
up and as the chairman has quite rightly
said there's nothing to stop them
tidying the site i mean if if
we were to say well every untidy site
that's outside the development boundary
can be built on which is basically what
we would be saying
if we agree to this then you know um
there's no point in bringing these
matters to a planning
committee because if we're just going to
go against all the policies
in the local development plan and and
against
the national planning policy framework
so i think we've got to think about
that these points you know the laws
that govern planning and not just about
our emotions and our thinking that it
would look better
if we agreed it um so i
i'm you know i do as i said have
sympathy
with this one but it's against our ldp
and it's against the nppf so i can't
agree to it
thank you chairman thank you um
council keys
oh hear me on the other ward member
and i totally support what councillor
siddal's done you know i had said my bit
last time there's no point in saying it
all again
it it's a rural area and
yeah it's yeah no i've got nothing to
say it was all said last time everybody
could listen back to what i said before
thank you thank you councillor keith
uh right i have no one on my list to
speak after councillor keys
um mr lee would you like to come back
before we go to the vote
uh thank you chairman um
i'll just get my camera on for
everyone's disappointment
um obviously a few members have raised
some points
um
firstly one of the points likewise that
obviously
certainly there is an allowance for all
diversification within policies and
employment uses within the rural areas
obviously this is very different
to the provision of residential dwelling
which country is just
country to policy um furthermore
stating that government guidance clearly
states brownfields should be supported
in
within segment boundaries and then going
this is outside of settlement boundary
and therefore it's in accordance with
this is not something we can
say because that's clearly conflicts
with exactly what the mppf says and
you know this is an application that was
refused by this planning committee only
three months ago
this has not been changed this has had a
very limited and i've been very limited
level of additional support information
and some criticism of officers
rather than actually an amendment to the
scheme
yeah the point is you know to really
wrote back
applications must be determining
currents with event planners material
considerations indicate otherwise
as members know from advice from
officers and from appeals that have been
made
something of a significant way is a
previous decision
this this committee only three months
ago refused this application
um whether you're not you agree with
the on whether or not how you voted at
the last committee to a certain extent
becomes a moot point
your starting point as a decision maker
is with the law
is with the planning process which is
what does the policy say
what way is in favor or against the
proposal this is no different to when
officers get an application in
after an application has been refused
overturned and refused
our starting point then becomes the
reasons refusal
what members need to be looking at as
decision makers
is have the reasons refused from the
committee decision
and i emphasize that again because
sometimes members like to think there's
a difference but there isn't
a committee decision only three months
ago have those reasons for approv
refusal been challenged successfully and
has additional information or amendments
been made to overcome them
as stated there are no amendments to
scheme and there's a rather
minor additionality in relation to
the employment and some criticism
officers i do not think that these go to
the heart of the region's refusal
previously
and that should be the fundamental basis
of this application
and that's even before we move on to
actual the value of the decision
because you know you may well see at the
items that are recommended for refusal
committee after a previous refusal that
officers might not agree with
but that's how the planning system works
and that would still be our
recommendation
and so that's just the point of clarity
i think i think councillor bamford and
durham reference a lot of the points you
know
uh that maybe i would have covered and
as counselor key said we've probably
discovered
discussed a lot of these points uh and
the last item so there's no point
repeating them can't blanch but um but
just to emphasize on something that
councillor bamford said
the site yeah i don't disagree the site
is untidy but as we discussed this
extensively three months ago
you know that buildings and sites have a
natural life and they move through them
that
there is no need for plant fishing to
improve that or to repair it
um there's no evidence to say that this
couldn't come back as a new employment
site because they have not evidenced
that
that's one of the you know policy
requirements they haven't done but
a statement saying that basically
because of an industrial site or an
agriculture site etc is untidy
it should be allowed to be go to housing
is unbelievably dangerous
partly because it can be regurgitated
across the district but also it's
encouraging
people that have sites to let them get
into a state of disrepair
because then we're going to allow them
there is nothing in our policy that
backs up that position
there is nothing in our policy that
backs up such a direction of travel
which could be used firstly against us
as you know just a general position but
actually
proactively managed to deliver something
that would actually
go against what our policies state um
i think i've probably covered most the
points
or also as i said council darwin bamford
have covered as well so i won't
keep up any once more's time thanks
thank you all right katie could we um
take the vote please i haven't got
anyone else asking to speak
thank you chairman so we are voting to
refuse the application as per the
officer's recommendation
of members i will take your names in
alphabetical order please if you could
state for
against or abstain thank you
councillor bamford
councillor durham or
jarvis
against keys
against councillor morley
against besido
against councillor thompson
oh
three four and four against no
abstentions
okay members clarity i'd like to
highlight obviously the slight
difference with this application is that
members reason for approval is going to
have to deal with the fact that it was
refused as well three months ago by this
committee
um and obviously
i think we're probably looking for a
proposal from you unless someone else
has got one
so now my proposal is that we approve
this
uh application the reasons being s8
the reuse of a redundant or disused
building that would lead to an
enhancement to the immediate setting
d1 built environment a positive
contribution
and to the natural environment on policy
f
that good enough well it's not up to me
chairman my advice would be in one word
no um
firstly these this is not reuse of
redundant building
um and secondly policy essay
lays down a number of criteria
that where we will support redevelopment
of sites
and none of them are um
market housing and to reference the
appeal decision
that i've made reference to earlier
for only last week from the 18th of
september
at hackman's lane that is exactly what
the inspector said
so actually the use of sa is a very very
dangerous
point because nowhere in that policy
does it support
the provision of market housing and that
is what this scheme is for
so my advice to members would be that
that is not the correct
direction of travel as it completely
just throws the ldp under a bus one of
the better phrase
so what about d1 um
d1 is a subjective point in relation to
design so
all planning is subjective
unfortunately
sorry chairman i apologize but um no
because some points are quite
clear has evidence been submitted yes or
no such as has this property been
marketed for
a period of time no so that that's not a
subjective point
for clarity but
um none of those points or any of that
point of just saying that the
site is arguing is not challenging the
fact that only three months ago the
this planning committee refused this
application
that is the intrinsic part as decision
makers
we need to be starting from those
reasons for refusal from three months
ago and looking to see what has changed
a personal opinion whether it's
as i said even my professional or my
as i right
just because you do or don't agree with
something
isn't whether it's a policy or that it
becomes a certain of a mute point when
there's planning history on the site
because that becomes the starting point
for the decision making process
and that is where this one is total is
very fundamentally different to the last
item we just had
we need to drill into what has happened
in the last three months
that means that the reasons for refusal
that the council considered were
unacceptable
are now falling away and the fact that
members voted for
against it last time is irrelevant
just like if for example you didn't like
a scheme
um and then it was allowed to appeal
when they came back for a slight
amendment
your recommendation would be that you'd
have to support it or if it was refused
on two reasons only one only one of them
stood up at appeal and they came back
we wouldn't be able to use that previous
reason for refuse was a new reason
that's so we have to look at the
starting point is the planning history
of this site and
what you've stated is based on a certain
level of subjectivity in relation to
d1 um a policy s8 which isn't useable
because it actually is totally contrary
to policy sa
so that actually is unhelpful for your
position as it's a reason for approval
but none of that challenges why it was
unacceptable three months ago but is now
acceptable
thank you chairman
yeah so the constitution of this council
is different
to this committee is different to what
it was three months ago
there are different members attending
this time to last time so therefore the
different members have come with
different views and we've got a
different decision
for you chairman unfortunately not this
that's the fact is that just like when
members make a decision and an
application comes back that's the
starting point for officers
that if members come and go officers
come and go but it's the council's
decision and your starting point as a
decision-maker
as just like it is with mine is the
policies and
until situations such as the previous
history of the site
the fact that you like it or don't like
it whether it's proven or refused or
is irrelevant that's it isn't just about
the fact that the committee membership
has changed
you need to look at the reasons for
refusing why what's happened different
because otherwise
my advice to you as a professional my
professional advice to you as a decision
maker
and is that you should be starting with
the reasons for you shouldn't be turning
up at this committee
to look at this item um ill nouveau you
need to be starting you should have been
starting with it
from the reasons refusal from three
years ago so my reasons for
recommendation is that it is a
sustainable development
and it is going to improve the design
and the the the landscape in that
particular area
so i consider it a sustainable
development a sustainable area
is 0.4 miles from the nearest bus stop
it is enhancing the landscape is
enhancing the current site
and it is improving the design in that
particular
particular part of the village
that's my reason that i put forward as a
reason for
passing this application
okay what people think about secondly
this can i just
ask yeah i i don't think it was a
different committee three months ago
unless as i missed something but um well
we're missing two people today but with
oh hello no we can't okay it was
ostensibly northwest area committee
under whatever but
i think i will second it okay we need
what we need to do i think
rather than going around around the
circles like we did previously
is start from the the standpoint of that
mr lee suggests can we go through
the previous reasons for refusal one by
one and then collectively we can try and
find
uh mitigations against those hopefully
we
we will and we won't have to um
[Music]
sit here all night looking for reasons
but um if that's the starting point i
think that's where we should
where we should go chairman
sounds hopeful to me
any offers numbers
chairman perhaps mr lee could read out
one by one
the previous reasons and then we'll
we'll see where we get to on that
sorry mr lee okay
i'm just trying to find him in the
report
if any of the officers got them in front
of them
um dude jeremy uh miss heinz park heinz
for clarity they're the same reasons for
views weren't they yeah
well that is interesting
for you chairman if you don't mind i'll
share my screen because that will show
them
that should be that so is everybody able
to see that
uh yeah so yeah i think it's coming up
those are the two reasons for views
obviously the second least refusal
relation to section 106 obviously if
members are to support the scheme
we would be saying we suggest that they
look to
delegate subject to the completion of
that
agreement the reason for
fuse in relation to the first one out
there can you see it
can you not uh what's that
no i have got your council jarvis yes
all right stop sharing
are they in fact the same what can you
point out the differences or can
just park there is no differences at
all no can we put them back up
sorry can anybody
well there was there was one i think
there that offers a glimmer of hope
so the application site lies within a
rural location outside of fine segment
boundary where policies restraint apply
the council can demonstrate a five-year
land supply to accord with the
requirements of the national planning
policy framework
the site has been identified by the so
it's not being identified by the council
for development to meet the future needs
for the district and does not fall
within either a garden suburb or
strategic allocation for growth
identified within the malden district
local development plan
to meet the objectively assessed needs
for housing in the district
the site is poorly located relative to
facilities services sustainable motor
transport
the proposed development would result in
the loss of employment use and it has
not been demonstrated
to the satisfaction of the lpa that
there is no demand for
employment use of this site furthermore
the pros would
substantially alter the character and
intrinsic beauty of the countryside
particularly through
the introduction of a domestic character
and dense form of residential
development
consciously existing grain of resident
development in and i can't see for
councillor durham
rural area the development would
therefore be unacceptable
and obviously just highlights the
policies there to currently see
um because i think one of the points
that we haven't really discussed
is the fact that this isn't a lot of
employment
site they have not done some of the
criteria
as the policy lays out that it's
explicitly states they should do
and every applicant has a right to be
treated the same
so if this application if this applicant
hasn't done
certain points members will need to
highlight
why that is acceptable in this instance
otherwise
it'd be reasonable for every applicant
to think that certain points of the
policies are no longer necessary to be
met
which obviously is a very dangerous
position to be in so if members are to
have approved this they need to
either highlight the exceptional
benefits of this scheme that
mean that policies become irrelevant or
why
this site specifically doesn't need to
meet certain points of policies
thank you chairman thank you chairman
the only thing i can think about
is that the improvement to the street
scene
can you can argue that it perhaps
outweighs all of the other policy
reasons why it shouldn't go ahead
because none of us
none of us fall out with the fact that
it's
not you know it's definitely going to
improve the street scene
um whether you you know
through you chairman all i would say is
if this was three months ago i'd say
fine but this committee refused this
three months ago so
my advice is that that is not robust i'm
plucking at straws mr lee but at that
time
that's about the only thing in that in
those reasons for refusal that i
yeah because nobody's gonna nobody's
going to say that it's not going to
improve the appearance
the only issue is that three months you
know that's where
the professional advice is that you know
we're not challenging why
what what's significantly happened in
the last three months and
that's really where the starting point
is should be for members
in this decision-making process so i i i
would stipulate
that that yeah in terms of the refusal
three months ago and in terms of the
refusal now the proposal would
substantially alter the character
intrinsic beauty of the countryside
particularly
to make an introduction domestic
character and dense form of residential
development consciously the existing
grain of
residential in this rural area i would
dispute any of that was true
last time as a refusal so i i
i would disagree that with that as a
reason for refusal
and i i would say that it would the
opposite is true
for you chairman for point of planning
law that's
on that's a flawed approach
unfortunately
and that'd be my advice um whether or
not you agreed with it last time is not
the starting point
and i'm not saying anyone would jr this
decision
um but these are the sort of scales of
applications that have been jailed here
at modern district council and i would
say that
it's difficult but i would say that an
approach that just is saying that i
didn't agree with it last time and i
don't agree with it now
irrespective of this application is not
the correct approach to coming to
determination of a planning application
you need you need to be showing that
you're being a reasonable in the wensby
term
what would the man on the clapper memory
bus say and if you aren't able to
demonstrate that you probably shouldn't
be saying it
and well i would say that we are able to
say that
chairman i again i can't i can't
disagree with councillor civil and i
can't recall that particular meeting
you know there's so much has happened in
between but
it does seem a bit bizarre that that was
a reason for refusal
the first time around because yeah
i seem to recall council spoke against
it which is absolutely decided
to do but that's not the decision that
helps why
but i have got counselling obvious
waiting to speak so
um councillor jarvis please yeah thank
you chairman i was just waiting for a
slot
um yes i mean um
i'm sort of puzzled a little bit
obviously i noted uh
the comment that was made regarding the
fact that it was refused last time
um but if uh if we if that
carries such weight that uh um we're not
able to make a different decision
i'm sort of getting my head around why
it's coming at all um
to committee or what the application was
being considered if that was carrying so
much weight
um that we can't uh that we can't sort
of review
aspects um it's a bit puzzled find that
a bit puzzling
as a sort of uh you know sort of an
issue if we're not allowed
to revisit the situation then it seems a
bit
unusual to me i mean i assume there are
some different aspects in the
application otherwise
why would we why would we be looking at
it um
but just before well to answer that
point for you
chairman for clarity um
the council only has the power to return
or to refuse to term an application if
it's been two within
the last two years um this obviously is
the only one
so that's well but otherwise and we do
it we do express
use our power to actually decline to
determine applications the reality is
this application my personal
professional opinion is that the
applicant should have gone to appeal
rather than resubmitting to us um this
is an attempt to see if the committee
will come to a different decision to
previously
which it shouldn't be doing it should be
going to appeal and let the inspect
determines my professional opinion
thank you yes thank you obviously
chairman i'm
sort of slightly confused there because
um obviously it seems to
be that the application has come to us
with the as officer
said to see whether the council would
make a different decision and
from what i've heard a number of
councillors would be keen to make a
different decision
um and so i'm still a little bit
concerned as to whether we're being told
we can
can can consider it or not but certainly
i think from what i've heard
from a number of councillors yeah we all
agree it's a pretty ugly site
and we all and some of the comments that
were clearly made last time
um i don't recall it um uh the fact that
it's uh um
sort of intrusion on the countryside um
you know that we
it's obviously an ugly site and it would
be good to put something better there
um i don't believe it's sort of mass
urbanization that we're talking about
it would improve the intrinsic value of
that countryside looking at a few nice
properties
rather than the ugly tin shacks that are
there i think
most people seem to think um that would
be right
the only other point i'd like to make is
just on the loss of employment
it sounded as if there was a
technicality whereby
um the person the applicant perhaps
could have
uh confirmed the details regarding loss
of employment all i can say is i hope
nobody's still working there
because it looks pretty derelict to me
but perhaps i've misunderstood that
point
thank you chairman thank you probably i
mean the point is part of the policies
are that certain
advertisements and criteria have you
know have to be made and met
and they haven't been just like with
removing for instance the agricultural
type
of dwelling you know you can't advertise
it for a month and so well i've
advertised it
you know rules about how long um
and it could be the site could be
repurposed with different buildings uh i
have councillor morley's handout
council morley yes thank you chairman um
my point was a
bit like councillor jarvis when was it
actually last youth
for industrial or employment and is it
likely to be really
as well thank you we don't know
i don't know when it was done whether or
not it's likely to be we don't know
because they've not done the
due diligence that we require for our
policy to give us the answer
um that's the point they've not marketed
it um the site should be marketed
at a reasonable rate and that and
potentially
someone may wish to redevelop it or
improve it we don't know though that's
and that's one of the worries i have is
that this with this
approach being taken on this site such
this is twofold one
oh it's a bit tatty it's a bit
degenerated though it doesn't matter
and the second one it's not in a great
state well no one's automatically going
to want to use it therefore
it doesn't matter because that's two
very key strands of policies that are
just
the reality is that may well be true but
they what we need evidence planning is
based on evidence it's not a heart it's
a head
based process as i said earlier and the
evidence hasn't been provided to us and
that's what my
concern is this is just going to make
defending other sites and because why is
it in this
instance except will not provide the
relevant evidence and to
munch demonstrate there's no need when
in other sites
we argue there is and without having
some specifics for this site it's a
worry because
as i've said before and i'll say again
when appellants
show an inconsistent approach by the
council the inspector normally falls on
the side of
allowing the appeal not dismissing the
appeal and
you know i'm getting to be honest i'm
worried about the amount of
inconsistencies
that are coming through at the moment
and the ability for the council in the
next
number of months and years to be able to
robustly defend appeals
with what's happening recently thank you
chairman
thank you i've got councillor bamford
but you know the site will be greatly
improved by a
you know a nice stand of trees and some
grass
as far as i know there wouldn't be any
great difficulty with
doing that i mean there's no obligation
to
fill it with houses just because we
don't like the look of it council
bamford
thank you chairman i was just trying to
help really in
trying to establish something had
changed in the last three months
and i'm just looking at the report in
relation to policy e1
i know you've said that they haven't
given any evidence
but the policy give us a paragraph
yeah it's five two two
yeah and it you know these three parties
says that the
um whether the sites are designated or
undesignated will only be considered
if the present use and activity on site
significantly harms the character and
immunity of the adjacent area
or the site would have a greater benefit
to the local community
if an alternative use were permitted
or the site has been marketed well you
said that the site hasn't been marketed
but could we not say that those two
other points are significant
um in this case um i'm just trying to
establish something
that might have happened in the last
three months do you chairman
um i don't actually agree with with
agreeing this as you know i'm just
trying to help yeah now i i understand
um clarity yeah i'm quite happy to try
and
help but you know we know there is no
use
on the site at the moment so there is no
harm in
noise disturbance etc um from the site
and i don't think we could argue
anything's particularly changed in that
respect in three months
in relation to point two i would advise
with all my professional being that we
do not say that residential use
is better than employment because
otherwise you've just literally said we
don't have we'll have any employment in
the district on any site so please do
not go down with that room members
i beg you and it's not rare that i'll do
something like that
and in relation to the third one
obviously that's about the
the points of needing evidence which
they've just not given us
thank you chairman thank you
i think we might be back with you
council i mean in the end it's it's your
proposal
and um you know at some point it's
almost anything we say will be used
against us at some point but
it's you know your proposal if you spell
it out to us
so you can get a second uh so i
the reasons that where i feel that we
should uh i'll go back to my original
reasoning
is that uh we should we should pass this
application
because it would improve the natural
environment by restoring land
to countryside it would improve the
visual impact in the street scene
in the area it would improve the built
environment
and provide a positive contribution to
the surrounding
area those are my reasons
and that's all d1
thank you that sounds clear enough to me
thank you you've got a second we're in
the shape of
councillor keys um
anything about conditions can we leave
conditions to delegate it to the
officers
in conjunction with myself and the board
members
and the section 106. thank you
thank you very much um katie could we
have
the roll call for the vote please
yes chairman so we are voting to approve
the application
contrary to the officer's recommendation
with the legal agreements and conditions
delegated to
officers subject to a section 106
agreement
in consultation with the chair
councillors i'll call your name in
alphabetical order please can you state
clearly
for against or abstain starting with
councillor bamford
against thank you councillor durham
thank you councillor jarvis
councillor jarvis that's my jarvis
sorry chairman uh just uh needs to tune
in there
um four okay thank you
councillor keys four
thank you councillor morley
four thank you councillor
four and council and mrs thompson
against that is
four four three against and no
abstentions
okay thank you very much um
so that is approved subject to certain
matters being delegated to the offices
the chairman of the committee and
the two award members so moving on
that's our final
planning application i think uh twenty
to the glue pearly
um we have two submissions
which will be read after the
presentation by mr johnson thank you so
much please thank you chairman
can everyone see that not
yes yes i can
thank you planning permission is sought
for the construction of a dropped curb
and vehicle crossing to allow access
using the side and front garden as a
driveway this is a resubmission of the
previously refused application twenty
zero zero two two one which was refused
as the development would be an
incongruous feature within the street
scene
whereby such features are largely absent
along this section and the southern side
of the gleam
under this application the driveway will
be constructed of grass creek the
dropped curb has increased in width by
0.3 meters and additional information
has been supplied
this can be found in section 3.1.4 of
the officer's report which is page 55.
this is the location plan
this is the proposed block plan
this is the block plan from the previous
application just to show that it has
increased in size
and these are photographs of the site
whilst is acknowledged that the
provision of on-site parking would be
desirable by the occupiers of the
dwelling it is considered
that these benefits are outweighed by
the harm and the impact of the
development
to the character and appearance of the
area the proposed amendments to the
scheme
are acknowledged to result in a more
sympathetic development than that of the
previous proposal
however the alterations are not
considered to overcome the harm
identified
therefore it is recommended that
planning permission is refused on this
basis
thank you chairman thank you
um mr johnson please um
submission one from the supporter and
submission two from the applicant
thank you thank you
we are residents of purley who live
adjacent to this proposal
uh of a drop curve leading to a future
driveway
we feel strongly as well as other
neighbors here
that it would be very beneficial having
two less
cars been parking on this sometimes busy
road
my wife and two young children have to
frequently
cross this section of road on their way
to school
or park and live or park and the view
of an of an off and on
sorry of oncoming traffic can be
obstructed by cars being parked on the
side of the road
thank you chairman uh just apologies for
the uh
um it's like this um
pronunciation sometimes in the how it's
written
submission two from the applicant
i wish to clarify several aspects of our
application that have become confused
and or misrepresented
we are not a detached property and there
is no hedging to either our northern or
western boundary as stated in the report
the application seeks approval to add a
dropped curb and crossover
the materials listed and indicated on
the plans are
suggested by the pre-application advice
the character appearance and function of
the grass verge will therefore be
largely preserved
as the materials will allow much of the
grass to grow back
in a short period of time the appearance
of the
of the replaced area will be restored to
that of a grass verge
the proposed parking area on our
property will accommodate two vehicles
not the one vehicle as referred to in
the report
consequently
consequently reducing the need for
on-street parking even further
the proposed parking spaces on our land
will be constructed within permitted
development rules
the area of the proposed drop curb and
crossover is 4.5 meters by 6.5 meters
part of which is already tarmac for the
footpath and is less than noted in the
report
there has also been down plane
of recent planning decisions which might
support our application
the crossover at 30 the glebe was
approved in 2004.
the report fails to mention that an
application in respect of 31 the glebe
was approved by molden district council
on the 1st of september 2020
to create a crossover to their property
this will result in the loss of verge
and without the ameliorating effect
of constructing the crossover using gas
crete
or similar our full response to the
refusal
of our first application has not been
included in the report
and copies of these have now been
forwarded to the board councillor
miss s white and the clerk for the
committee's information
finally in light of the above we would
invite the committee
to reject the officer's recommendation
and to approve the application
thank you chairman
thank you um
[Music]
right um do i either of your office at
the offices
any of your offices want to make any
comments before we go to
the recommendation i'm with you
councillor morley i'll come back
if not then i will put the
recommendation
which is to refuse for the reasons as
detailed in
section 8 of the report do i have a
second to get that on the table
nobody okay then i need a proposal
please from someone else otherwise we
have nothing to debate
unfortunately this i'll second it maddie
thank you i was waiting for someone else
to speak i thought
nobody has i can't emphasize enough that
it
does not obligate anyone
to vote for either their proposal or
their second because they haven't heard
the debate yet so how could they
thank you so much councillor right we
have something to debate it is the
recommendation to
refuse as i say unfortunately this was
called in
by one of the i don't mean that bit is
unfortunate unfortunately
the ward member who called it in isn't
here nor is the other ward member so
we'd like to go first
council mauling sorry you did pop your
hand up before
yes sorry i'm all fingers and thumbs
here i do apologize
um i just the reason for refusal is it
not better to have
carls off the road then or is that um
it seems advantageous really to have
them off the road as the
applicant was saying on the face of it
absolutely could we see the photographs
again please
haley he's parking you thinking
because i'm not familiar with this road
i won't make a comment counts keys about
my friend who's the lorry driver
you'd have probably just gone through
the vehicles but that's a different
connotation um but i just wanted to
comment on a
council morley's point the reason for
refusal
um is in relation to
basically um
aesthetic appearance um the erosion of
the grass verge
um but what also as the officer's report
explains
the while there's the members public
saying they
would be cav it could accommodate two
cars in our policy terms it would only
accommodate
one reasonable sized car um obviously
the starting point is policy position
and what we would class say
uh car parking space to be um just for
clarity
thank you could um
i mean i understand the report don't
please don't misunderstand me but
um no not a problem so this is the tree
that's planned to be removed so the drop
kerb will be located in this sort of
location
okay and this is hey you want to show
the block
plan and on the other photo
on this photo this is views to the east
of um the application site so that was
just mainly to
um show members that there are no other
curbs within the vicinity
and then this is to show the changing
character of area
towards the west of the site um but
um yes the block plan as you can see
here members this is
the show you can explain it the grass
area that's going to be removed
yeah so this is the grass verge at the
moment with the the public footpath here
which you can very uh just about say
the dotted line which denotes the verge
from the pathway
so they park in the road are they anyway
at the moment
there are designated lay-bys um along
the glave and on this side of the road
and also um i believe there are other
parking
available i didn't realize they were
designated
okay thank you yeah that helps me
quite a lot um could it be grass created
or whatever reliably
could that be conditioned and would it
work mr lee
um anybody uh through chairman um
obviously officers as the report says
you know
we can condition that it would be that
um
whether or not officers got concerns of
that would overcome the harms it still
wouldn't it would still erode the
grass verge which obviously is an
attractive feature in the street scene
and result in the loss of the tree
so officers opinion are that they're
that's just a fundamental issue that
this won't overcome but um
yeah that's it could be imposed if
members think it overcomes the harm
okay within their gift
okay and any other member
[Music]
right firstly i think the officers put
the wrong picture up at the beginning of
this
presentation um it's not the same as the
picture that's on the
um the agenda in the pack
that we have so that might have confused
things a bit
now i've been reading what the parish
council have said
and they seem to be uh quite strongly
against this happening
um and i can understand
some of the objections however the
applicant i think it was who um mr
johnson read out their
present read out what they said they
said that
certain other properties in glebe
um road is it or avenue um
had put dropped curbs in
and i wondered if those are on the side
with the green um
the green area or not because i think
the other side doesn't have
the green verge so that that was one
question
where were those other drop curves my
other question is
if this was allowed um i think you asked
this question already chairman
um could we enforce having the tree
reinstated and the grass reinstated
either side of the driveway
um and really are there are the
other driveways along this glebe
um that go across this grass verge
um or or is this the only request
which seems to be at the end so if that
makes any sense sorry i'm
not in the best of health at the moment
as you can probably hear
um so yeah
okay um
thank you chairman i think i can i can
answer this all right thank you
sorry um
no no no no um
in relation to the query about the
location of the other dropped kerbs
it's at number 30 the glebe so um
it's quite a few properties to the east
of the application site
and so it's quite a distance and there's
one that's recently been approved
in that location too thank you
okay thank you chairman do they go
across
this grass
so i don't know if you could catch that
sorry they're
they're on the opposite side of the road
aren't they though no these
these are on the same side of the road
but the grass verge isn't
um as prominent in that location it's a
lot narrower
but tell me what could someone who's
swifter than i am get google earth
you know google thingy up on of course
that's what i'm trying to look at
ah well done anybody um
mr lee you're fairly swift with these
things
no no comment chairman um
um i've got to google straight up um
hey you want to give us a bit of a
direction what to do with it though
just drop down on the bleep that's even
less helpful comment
yeah i can't see your screen though
can you not see can anyone see my screen
yes i can see it oh you've taken you've
taken control
i can see there's a screen i can see
a black hole so this is the drive
this is the driveway to the to the east
of the site
yeah and then our application these are
the designated lay-bys for parking
yeah okay and then this is our
application site here
yeah it's not quite the same is it no
it's it
no no it's not no it's not the same
sorry can we
is that tree being removed yeah it's
cancelled
keys
yeah i just wanted to add to that
because i do recall um the decision on
um the other site where there is the
existing
crossover um adjacent the the
infringement upon the grass verse was
quite minor that was the reason
why that decision was taken so we are
looking at a completely different
situation thank you mr johnson sorry um
can i just confirm that's the tree we're
looking at that's going
would go yeah
um
um the applicant doesn't have ownership
of land either side of
this so we won't be able to require the
tree to be
replaced on so
but they do have they do have um
ownership of the birds estimating it's
highway land
well that's the question i was going to
ask
again are they going to nick a piece of
highways land then
i'm not really sure about that
[Applause]
it is highway land obviously since i
have the rights to do that um
obviously we're not unitary so we
haven't got quite as much of a ability
to answer certain questions which you
can in other
pla places and ability to maybe be a
little bit more robust in certain
matters but it may well be that highways
would say no but that's not a
part of the decision-making process for
us the highways own the
top couple of spades worth or something
don't they because
this came up in in a village of mine
with a walkable verge
and the landowner said what if i don't
give permission and highway
said we control even if you own it and
it's on your deeds we still control
the top two spacewolf council bamford
will remember where i mean
so there's nothing actually to stop
highways coming along and concreting it
or re-grasping it or whatever they're
liking it
presumably that right i'm not happy i'm
not sure that
we're in a position to really know what
we're doing myself
and that that puts me very much in favor
of the recommendation
so if anyone else has something else to
offer please do
otherwise i'd like to go to the vote uh
i i think chairman yeah thank you i
don't think it's going to improve the
street scene very much and i would
support the recommendation
i'm just getting ready for the vote
chairman oh okay
um right no one else has indicated they
wish to speak
so yeah katie could we vote please which
this time we're actually looking at the
recommendation which is to refuse
yes chairman um thank you so we are
voting
to refuse the application as per the
officer's recommendation
members i'll take your names in
alphabetical order please state clearly
for against or abstain councillor
bamford
thank you councillor dharam four thank
you
councillor jarvis paul
thank you councillor keys
four thank you councillor morley
four thank you councillor
four thank you and councillor mrs
thompson
oh 274
none against and no abstentions
thank you very much right i'm back
tomorrow
right we are on item 8 which is any
other items of business the chairman of
the
committee decides emergent there are
none of those
so i'm going to close the meeting
with even more than my usual thanks to
all contributors but particularly
the officers in this case who i know you
work very hard and this can't be an easy
way to work
um so thank you for your contributions
this afternoon i draw the meeting to a
close
at i make that 3 40.
um and as the meeting is closed members
are advised not to enter into further
discussions on this forum and please to
leave the meeting promptly thanks
everyone bye
you